Jeter played 20 years as shortstop for
the New York Yankees and is a 14-time
All-Star won five World Series
Championships including three in a row
and recently celebrated his induction
into the Baseball Hall of Fame and he
went to the field at Yankee Stadium to
join all of his best friends for that
Derek joins us now uh thank you very
much for being here um you were one vote
shy of a unanimous induction
who is that who is the guy from herself
you know what look uh let me start I I
don't know who it is I don't care who it
is but I think a lot of times you know
members of the media they say athletes
have to be accountable
responsible so I think they should ask
answer that question as opposed to me
getting asked a question every time I go
I mean I would be interested
I found it irritating I know you say you
don't care yeah it irritated me just a
little bit we'll find out who it is
we'll get to the bottom of it we'll put
our eye team on it uh what was it like
for you walking back uh in the Yankee
Stadium uh for that uh ceremony
acknowledging your Hall of Fame career
it was great you know I hadn't been back
I had my head down in Miami for four and
a half years so I really didn't get a
chance to go back to Yankee Stadium too
often and you know feels like home when
you're there I mean I played 20 years we
were joking before saying New York's
like dog years yeah 140 year career and
uh it felt good to go back get a chance
to bring my girls there they had never
been to Yankee Stadium get to share the
moment with them but what is it like for
you and your girls are young so they
don't really know that Derek Jeter the
career of Derek Jeter but what's it like
when you look at the videos of yourself
and you see the crowd the Roar the crowd
what do you think when you look at
yourself in that light
I try not to look Yankee fans are the
best in the world I grew up with them
and um the support that they've given me
throughout my 20-year career I mean you
never forget that and and you can't
replicate going through an experience
like that 50 000 people chanting for you
cheering for you yeah um you miss it you
miss the interactions with the fans and
and that's why I say when I brought my
girls there I wanted them to at least
get a chance to experience it once but
the thing that I think makes you so
great Derek not only are you so amazing
on the field it's what you're like off
the field I've met your mom and dad your
sister your family is so fantastic your
wife is also spectacular I'm wondering
about how you were raised and what you
were taught because that's one of the
things I admire most about you I
appreciate it but you know I was tired
of a very close family I'm close with my
parents my sister as well now same thing
with my girls and my wife and and I
always just wanted to people I wanted to
treat people how I wanted to be treated
I think that's that's the number one
goal and and uh
I think you people talk about Legacy
what you have on the field but I always
wanted people to remember me who I
remember me for who I was as a person
and as an individual on the subject of
Legacy uh are you interested in going
back to the New York Yankees and maybe
an executive role yeah people keep
bringing that up well it would make them
have not had those conversations at all
look I like I said I had my head down
for quite some time and and you know now
I value I'm still all over the place
doing a lot of things but I value family
time as well yeah that's a full-time job
you know you're a player you don't
understand how many hours go into the
front office so I have a newfound
response so how removed you are from the
outcome on the field I mean you're
watching from the booth and you can make
some moves with emails but you're not
playing it's frustrating it is very
frustrating not to be able to impact the
outcome of a game just up there and
trying to watch patiently yeah let me
ask you about
um this beautiful photo that you shared
on Instagram of your daughter's uh
painting your nails I love that yeah
it's such a cute look at this photo
I love it
um you what is your favorite girl dad
activity do you have any advice for girl
dads I'm about to be one in January yeah
congratulations keep them alive
every day yeah I mean advice is is you
know you just gotta jump in you know
it's it's there's I you know I always
valued myself on being prepared and you
can't prepare for this I mean it's new
experiences my girls I love my girls
they all have
different personalities they're caring
they're smart they're curious
um and they're beautiful and you know I
just want to be there for it for them to
help them find something that they're
passionate about just like my parents
did with me and and you'll do just fine
oh thank you but I like what you said
Derek you're very busy off the field
whether you go to the Yankees or not a
lot of people are hoping you do of
course that's that's a personal question
you said nobody's even having those
discussions but us you might be having
those thoughts but we'll let them have a
thought well you know but but I like
that you've started in a Peril line and
I like that you're with Misty Copeland
good choice Wayne Gretzky and apparel
line that does what what's it called
well I mean I've I've had relationships
with athletic brands my entire career
um I say my whole life I've been wearing
it and anytime you do that you think of
things that you would like to improve on
and things that you would do differently
and uh so we launched greatness wins a
few months back and I've partnered with
the founder of untuckit Wayne Gretzky
the incomparable Misty Copeland I
brought on to how did you pick this me
and my wife were sitting around thinking
about who we like to lead the women's
line and she was the first name that
came to us yeah so it's got good taste
yeah so I I encourage you we focus first
and foremost on performance I think a
lot of times people lose sight of the
fact the sports apparel Branch should
focus on performance highest quality fit
consistency sustainability so I
encourage everyone to go to
greatnesswinds.com especially with the
holidays coming up